[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
season 5 of fortnite chapter 2 has begun
and the map has been overhauled and it's
absolutely packed with things to see and
do
this is the series which has been going
three years now we look at all the map
updates on fortnite island and link
everything we can to storyline
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap code adamaru to support this
nonsense and let's break down
season five okay so the zero point is
back
in action after fending off galactus
attack on the island
everything has changed thanks to the
zero point and multiple realities
coming together if you want to see the
event without any commentary i'll add a
link
but today we're not going over those
events today it's all about map goodies
and the first thing you should do
is jump through the zero point there is
no reason to do this
but it feels cool
[Music]
so let's start at stealthy stronghold a
new octagon of weird up by the
lighthouse
this place gives me serious jurassic
park vibes
with a walled off jungle tentatively
held by those gates
there is actually raptor-sized cages
opened in this area so we may see a
dinosaur in the coming weeks what's that
one with a long neck
what's it called ally diplodoculus a
diplodocus thanks brother
but seriously though this place has a
secret there are buildings here shacks
and temple ruins
but check underneath and you'll find the
first hidden bunker of the season
down here is a modern office with books
opened at specific pages
but alas we cannot make them out but
now's the time to uncover this new logo
the order these guys will play a pivotal
role this season
as we uncover who the heck they are my
money is on agent johnsy
the logo is like a cog design and the
only other cog based logo i know
is is mine i've said too much
let's move on
[Music]
next let's start traveling down to the
logjam factory
formerly a place to get wood but now the
derburger restaurant has reappeared from
chapter one
the nostalgia hits you hard when you see
this perfectly recreated from the season
five
of chapter one it even still has this
poster i think you should add your own
mum joke this week
anyway before it was closed down and the
food fight begun can you remember what
the poi was called that it was attached
to in chapter one
i'll be in the comments to give you
praise but right now this version does
not have the iconic mascot on top
and i'm sure you already remember where
it is it's in the woods just nearby both
the derburger and the pizza pit head
sit dormantly here for over a year i'd
love to see this head rolled over slowly
and put back on top
i guess we'll wait and see so if the der
burger is back then so should be the
pizza pit joint right
and yes it sure is up at the old farm
orchard
is the building but to my surprise the
mascot
is already on top i'm shooketh to the
core
this is definitely the chapter one
version of the restaurant because we can
see the old signs from the day the
tomato had vanished
we'll break down all that law another
time there's too much on the map to get
through this week
let's put a pin in that the mandalorian
became one of jones's first hunters and
crash landed on the island his vessel
sits smoking in the sand
this is also nearby to another poi
hunter's haven
on the mountain top where the sentinels
laid last season a whole new colony for
hunters to live
and not right away the symbol of the
order the cogs of time and the
elements that control space may be one
building in particular needs your
attention more than
others look at this someone is building
a new vehicle
the brute 2.0 maybe a new way to travel
in fortnite is always welcome
and i personally quite like the brutes
feel free to throw shade at me in the
comments below i can take it
there's other cool details here like a
shame and like presentation mount worth
having a peek at
and you'll likely notice all the
parchments and scriptures in this poi
if you can translate any of these please
let me know but now
the greatest easter egg in fortnite
history going to this building
to find pili trapped in carbonite
for those who don't do star wars see
this like a prison cell his vitals are
on the side
bounty hunters regularly use carbonite
to freeze criminals and pick up multiple
contracts
at once i guess pele was on the naughty
list the hunter haven looks to be home
to all the hunters in the battle pass
with rooms dedicated to them such as
coliseum weapons
in this room but before we leave there
is a secret urban legend found here
during matches it's possible for a troop
of io soldiers to burst up through the
ground beneath us
legend has it if you're in this location
and you're lucky enough
the bromance from last season the
henchmen will arrive in your game
i dropped here 10 times but alas i never
saw the duo
i'm not one of the cool kids have you
found them yet
is the bromance really over or is it
still going on
well i guess now's a great time to look
at the colosseum here is one of the many
spots we can speak to npcs from the
battle pass and beyond to pick up
bounties or have a little help
my first recommendation is not to shoot
these guys
here at the colosseum you'll see some of
the most detailed statues ever created
including the future pili skin that must
arrive
this season peely caesar i also noticed
a really cool easter egg here depending
on your game mode
the pit will change in solos it's half a
viking ship and battlements but in team
rumble
it's the wooden llama and the crab
structures from chapter one
another chapter one reference please let
me know if you spot any other variations
i'll link my twitter and the discord
below speaking of viking ships over at
the mega store there is now a hulking
grape vessel
sat on top of the building and once
again it's the same one as chapter one
season five
we continue to loop everything is linked
together the store here isn't open yet
and those who thought this would be the
christmas store will be shukrth because
that's over at retail row this year
we'll get to that very soon a tiny
update in the crane house
the building interior has been updated
with a mystery person moving in
military storage and ammo is heaped here
this could be nothing or it could be
something very important
i will keep you updated either way all
you need to do is subscribe
yeah self promotion don't do that adam
the theme of chapter one and chapter two
colliding is apparent
everywhere on the island fyi
truckasaurus is still sunbathing by the
docks
but other places have returned well sort
of
the buildings that once formed dusty
depot yes i still say depot
i'm english please don't bully me they
have returned
and look at this sad mess now rip in
another anomaly
salty springs and the old tilted towers
have been realigned
to become salty towers although sweats
that love chaos will be happy about this
place returning
i wonder if one of the buildings will
continue to be smashed to pieces like it
did in chapter one
those were good memories my personal
favorite returning chapter one landmark
is this place it's flush factory
beautifully recreated even the spray
paint room returns
and look outside there is the oversized
toilet we all know and love
i've eaten so much during lockdown that
i'll probably need a toilet that's
reinforced like that soon
i i digress over the first few seasons
of this chapter this spot was a huge
mess of metal tubes
and as an fyi up the road from this is
another fast food truck
just in case you're hungry and to
finalize this chapter one input
up at pleasant park all but the gas
station have now been reverted to the
chapter one days
it's really strange to see dr doom's
castle a tiny little house again
the football slash soccer field is
closed tightly again too
going back to the new sandy area for a
moment take a look at these cabins that
have been set up to monitor the zero
point
each has a telescope aimed straight at
that sphere
last time we saw something like this it
was the meteor crater in chapter one and
a whole structure was built around that
point
that may happen again in the desert is
also another battle pass character a
sheriff found at the butter barn a
throwback to the old western town we had
in season x
but my real question around here are
these
what the heck are these purple things
are they related to kevin
they grant us mysterious powers too oh
and whilst i was testing this if you
haven't tried yet
just stand still in the sand you really
should you can now hide
expect so many videos from the entire
community trolling people with this
tactic
i feel like i feel like we're missing
something
hot watch baby the saga continues hut
watch
had its biggest update for years today
and now looks like a legit place of work
welcome to big shots a bar for the thick
characters to hang out in
only basic amenities are here right now
but the view from your table upstairs
is delightful maybe we'll get kyle from
save the world this season to come and
help penny run this place
there is still more to uncover let's
keep going get your butt over to retail
row and you'll see she hulk's home has
gone sadly but on the bright side
the christmas store has returned crack
out the mariah carey tunes
outside is the makeshift tree business
complete with a temporary shack
so we can expect the christmas trees to
be taken from here to all the pois
just like they did last season also note
one of the misfits has returned to the
island and currently sits in the back of
the new store
their story seems to pop up each year
with that in mind i traveled to the
bunker they hid in
and look it's been modernized new chairs
guess we should watch this space down at
lazy lake there isn't much of note but
you may want to jump into this house
here
and look around we have a golden vars in
here we also have a golden toilet the
one that was found
at the island before midas arrived in
season two and that is not all because
graham the gnome is here
he's been goldified that's totally not a
word but it
sounds good of course i checked on the
real graham and he's okay
near the boat graveyard sits a secret
ritual post which
looks to be a challenge for a battle
pass character it's extremely detailed
for a fortnight prop so i'm expecting it
to have some sort of importance
and if you're wondering the bifrost
scorches have now gone
rip the dream tony stark's battle bus
has now gone
yet we're back to the og one and the
helicarrier base was backhanded during
the event
but on the plus side we have the
original lobby island again
complete with the obstacle course but
the best thing of all is the return of
the teddy in the tower
the real overseer
right i think that's everything if i've
missed anything please whack it in the
comments and i'll make sure it's in next
week's episode
right now i'm going back to earn more
gold as mando i'm adam from playstation
grenade thank you for your time and
thank you very much to those who've used
code adam arrow today
i'll be sure to shout you out in the
next episode enjoy season five peeps
i'll see you soon